one day last week we had 200 000 people
test positive and the latest figure
today is another 218 000 though with uh
that includes some delayed reports
so anyone who thinks our battle with
kobit is over i'm afraid is profoundly
wrong
this
is a moment for the utmost caution but
our position today differs from previous
waves in two crucial respects first we
now know that omicron is milder than
previous variants so while hospital
admissions are rising quickly with over
fifteen thousand copied patients now in
hospital in england alone this is not
yet thankfully translating into the same
numbers needing intensive care that we
saw in previous waves second
thanks to the fantastic national effort
to get britain boosted we now have a
substantial level of protection higher
than any of our european neighbors with
over 34 million boosters administered
including in england reaching more than
90
of the over 70s and 86
of the over 50s
and so
together with the plan b measures that
we introduced before christmas
we have a chance
to ride out this omicron wave without
shutting down our country once again
we can keep our schools and our
businesses open and we can find a way to
live with this virus
but the weeks ahead are going to be
challenging both here in the uk and
across the world there is no escaping
the fact that some services will be
disrupted by staff absences
but we've been working through christmas
to prepare for this wherever possible
and if we all play our part in
containing the spread of this virus the
disruptions we face
can be far less severe than a national
lockdown with all the devastation that
would bring for the livelihoods and the
life chances of our children
so the government is acting to protect
critical national services to keep
supply chains open and fortify rnhs to
withstand the pressures ahead
we've identified a hundred thousand
critical workers
in areas from food processing to
transport to our border force
and from the 10th of january we'll be
rolling out lateral flow testing for all
these workers available on every working
day
we'll be sending testing kits directly
to these organizations and liaising with
them on the logistics
we've asked qualified teachers who have
left the profession to come back and
help fill temporary absences and i want
to thank them and all teachers parents
and pupils for taking the precaution to
test yourselves and to wear a mask in
the classroom enabling vital face to
face education to continue
we're increasing nhs capacity by
building on-site nightingale hospitals
as well as creating 2500 virtual beds
where people can be safely treated at
home
we've bought more antivirals per person
than anywhere else in europe those are
the tablets which reduce your chances of
going to hospital once you've caught
copied
we're mobilizing our volunteers the
emerging territorial army of the nhs and
we're working to identify those nhs
trusts which are most likely to need
actual military support so that this can
be prepared now
as our nhs moves to a war footing i will
be recommending to cabinet tomorrow that
we continue with plan b
because the public have responded and
changed their behavior change your
behavior buying valuable time to get
boosters in arms and help the nhs to
cope with the omicron wave
so please carry on observing those
measures for now work from home if you
can wear face coverings on public
transport and in indoor places and take
a test before you go to a high risk
venue or meet those who are elderly or
vulnerable and of course follow the
relevant rules if you live in scotland
or wales or northern ireland
above all if you haven't already done so
please please get that booster
since i launched the get boosted now
campaign on the 12th of december we've
delivered 10 million extra boosters
across the uk
we've doubled the rate of vaccination
from 450 000 doses a day to a peak
of more than 900 000.
we matched the nhs's previous record day
and then beat it again and again and we
met our target of offering a booster to
every eligible adult a whole month early
the freedoms we're able to maintain in
the teeth of this omicron wave have been
made possible by the number of people
getting boosted and i want to thank
again everyone who assisted in this
extraordinary national effort over
christmas our gps and their teams
pharmacists everybody in our fantastic
nhs the thousands of volunteers the
ingenious initiatives of local
communities like the one in red bridge
town hall which vaccinated 1700 people
on christmas day and every one of you
who has come forward and done your bit
by getting jabbed but
there are still almost nine million
people eligible who haven't had their
boost and it's absolutely heartbreaking
as many as 90 percent of those in
intensive care with covid have not had
their booster and over 60 percent of
those in intensive care have not had
with covid have not had any vaccination
at all
people are dying needlessly because they
haven't had their jabs and they haven't
had that booster
and there are two million booster slots
available this
week alone
it's already the case that to travel to
some countries you need a booster to be
considered fully vaccinated
and it's likely that within weeks this
will increasingly become the norm
so
if you haven't done it already get
yourself boosted this month
exactly a year after the uk administered
the first astrozenica vaccine a british
invention that has enabled 2.5 billion
jabs around the world the best way to
contain this virus help our nhs and keep
our country open is to get boosted so
please get boosted now thank you and
chris owed you for the slides thank you
prime minister first side please
uh this is a familiar slide the number
of people testing positive for cobit 19
in the uk
and i think everybody knows there's been
a very substantial increase over the
last few weeks
next slide please
i thought however it was probably
sensible because uh there are big
significant changes in the way testing
is done uh
better to actually just look
particularly at the office for national
statistics ons data uh which is uh in
the public domain and there'll be uh
updates on this soon
and as you can see this is uh these dots
represent how many people had coveted
various points in time going back to may
2020 using the same methodology
and the extraordinary increase on the
far right
where we've now got to the situation uh
where in the last week they have
reported uh 1 in 25 people in england
had covered more in some areas
around 2 million people in all and the
expectation is those numbers will in
fact go up
next slide please
the as several people uh have commented
and one of the good things that we've
learned since the last time we did a
press conference on this is uh data
both from south africa but also now all
around the world including uh the uk
demonstrating that there are lower rates
of hospitalization
but lower does not mean there are not
hospitalizations there are significant
numbers and just to give uh some kind of
feel for this
uh at the moment there are just over 15
000 people
in hospital in england the data here of
the uk and a slightly later in time if
we went back to mid-december when we
when we were there still with the delta
wave the number in hospital was between
six
thousand and six thousand five hundred
so a very substantial increase people
are not admitted to hospital in the nhs
in winter unless they have a clear need
uh for hospitalization
and then to compare it to the previous
waves uh the wave that we had in uh
in in the early part of 2020 uh had 18
974 people at the absolute peak so
we are relatively close to that initial
peak the january peak last year was
higher
next slide please
if we look around the country uh we can
see uh obviously quite a variety of
different patterns london has been in
advance of the rest of england
and indeed other parts of the united
kingdom
uh the numbers however are still going
up there may be some slowing but they
are still going up
and i think the thing which i'd like
just to add in terms of the local
epidemiology in london is that it does
look as if the numbers in younger adults
are leveling off or falling although we
need to be quite careful because this is
before new year effects have actually uh
taken taken effect
but
rates in older people look as if they
are still going up and these are the
people who are much more likely to be
hospitalized and the thing which is
likely to reduce that to go back to the
prime minister's point is the fact that
people have got boosted but anybody who
has not been boosted as eligible really
should do so i think the idea that this
is a miles disease as opposed to less
likely to be hospitalized i think it's
easily demonstrated to be incorrect
based on these data
next slide please
there's quite a bit of commentary and i
just wanted to put some numbers on this
about whether people have are primarily
in hospital because of kovid or because
they have it incidentally they have
another medical problem but they have
covert on top there are of course people
with both that's been true all the way
through the pandemic um the majority of
people who admitted uh and have coveted
uh i will have actually have coveted as
their primary reason for admission but
obviously there are people who that is
also a significant minority where that
is uh not the case there in blue
and the orange data are for people
who've got a primary diagnosis of coded
next slide please
one thing which we have seen and which
is obviously extremely extremely good
news compared to where we were with
previous waves is that the mortality
rate does not appear to have risen the
numbers have been artificially low over
the last two or three days because it's
a long weekend and will be artificially
high tomorrow but we are not seeing the
surge in mortality that we saw in in
previous waves but there will be people
particularly people who are vulnerable
for other reasons because of their age
or medical conditions who will uh sadly
die with us
next slide please
to the booster and
the vaccination campaign i think there
are really um two uh very uh important
uh positives to highlight the first of
which is the extraordinary speed with
which uh colleagues in the nhs and
volunteers
have been able to provide and people
have come forward for boosters and the
very rapid increase we've had
and additionally and this is extremely
important
people who have previously had no
vaccines have come forward for their
first vaccine and people who previously
had a first vaccine have come forward
for their second and this each one of
these will help provide additional
protection
but we now um have confidence that the
boosted the booster provides around 88
percent overall protection against being
hospitalized
and it is likely to be even greater than
that for severe disease and mortality
next slide please
and finally just a slide i've shown
before because i just want to emphasize
this that at every age band
the uh that being vaccinated whether
it's for previous variance and is likely
to be true for this uh variant
every age band people are significantly
protected by vaccination
and it is really critical whatever age
people are that they do get vaccinated
that we are confident this will also
lead to a reduction in people having
a booster lead to reduction in people
actually having kobit and therefore a
reduction in people's likelihood of
passing on kovid but the data are still
uh being developed so we don't have the
exact numbers but in terms of reducing
hospitalizations we are now confident
that boosting provides very significant
protection
and
that the
one or two vaccines provide some level
of protection
thank you very much indeed thank you
chris uh patrick
okay well let's let's go to uh questions
from
the uh the public and
we've got a question from david in kent
given the government has said it will be
guided by the data uh what level of
daily infections hospitalizations or
deaths will the government implement
tougher covered restrictions well thank
you dave i think that's the
uh the
the key question that many people have
been uh thinking about throughout the uh
the omicron uh pandemic and you you have
to think about omicron as a as a
as a disease an infection really uh
on it on its own as soon as we saw it
emerge
we we knew that
it was likely to present a problem and
if you recall we we put in measures on i
think december the 8th we introduced
plan b
and
i just want to say that i'm
incredibly grateful to uh the nhs to
everybody who's working so hard in our
hospitalization in our hospitals uh now
to uh to deal with uh the pandemic but i
do think that the the balance of
measures uh that we have is
the right one and uh the right one for
for omicron uh we'll continue to
to monitor it clearly but what we're
saying is that you've got to stick with
with plan b you've got to follow the
guidance you've got to make sure you
wear a mask in confined spaces on public
uh transport you've got to make sure you
you get a test uh before you go to a
venue we're going to meet people uh that
you don't normally meet uh you've got to
make sure uh that
you
for instance
do not
take unnecessary risk particularly with
uh with elderly people and above all uh
we've got to make sure that you get a a
vaccination and
that is the
the the most important thing
uh
we wanted to have a mixture of plan b
and
a greatly accelerated booster program
and i just want to say david that
it is
always difficult to balance these things
uh there is no
uh easy answer to
a uh
a problem like omicron uh there's no
easy lockdown there's no easy
restriction on people's lives or
or livelihoods and
uh
the best thing i think we can do now is
to continue to follow the guidance uh
protect our nhs in the way that uh that
we are
increase the the support that we're
giving uh to the nhs and and as you know
uh you heard from what i said earlier on
we're increasing the
uh the numbers of uh of staff where
we've got i think we've got a record
number of people working in the nhs uh
now than at any time in the past five
thousand more uh doctors ten thousand uh
more nurses uh you'll have heard what
i've said about all the the volunteers
but the best way to to help the nhs
is for everybody uh to
follow the guidance follow plan b
and above all get boosted and i just
want to return to that
that
earlier
tragic reflection that so many people
going into
uh the nhs uh so many people who are
being
are hospitalized sadly uh david uh have
not been vaccinated as i said uh about
61 percent of those uh in in icu have
not been vaccinated uh
at all and uh perhaps
90 percent uh have not been boosted so
the single best thing we can all do to
protect the nhs is to is to get boosted
and and to get vaccinated but
we will continue to uh to watch uh what
happens very closely
but we think that this is the right
the right approach to take
it's a balanced approach it has to
balance a lot of considerations it has
to balance the
uh
the effect on people's lives and
livelihoods of lockdowns which are
painful
uh which take away people's uh life
chances and which do a great deal of uh
of social
uh damage damage to people's mental
health as well as damage uh damage to
the economy so it's a difficult balance
to strike but that is that is where we
are anyway chris anything to answer on
thank you uh let's go to
amanda from cheshire
amanda says i had covered at the
beginning of november i was told by
tests and trace not to take a lateral
flow test for 91 days as a result may
not be accurate
so how is it now reliable to use the
results of these tests on days six and
seven to reduce the isolation period
does the 91 day period for not using
natural flow tests no longer apply
uh
chris i'm going to i'm going to defer to
you on this one thank you prime minister
um the the answer is the the key thing
which the lateral flow is really good at
um is it
is the fact that it
is a pretty good guide very good guide
actually to whether someone is at that
moment infectious
uh and so the reason that we feel it is
a useful tool to allow on day six and
day seven uh if someone is isolated
because they know they've got covered to
day five and then they have a negative
test on day six and a negative test on
day seven
we have confidence they're much less
likely
to be in any way infectious to other
people if they then leave isolation
than if um they had not done those tests
so that's the reason why adding those
tests on allowed ministers to decide to
move from 10 days isolation uh down to
seven but the last two you do the
lateral test because they're very
predictive of how infectious someone is
obviously if they're still positive then
they do need to stay in isolation till
it goes negative
the the pcr tests which are the other
way of testing they can remain uh
positive for a long time after someone
has had an infection including beyond
the point where they are uh infectious
so the reason that we find the pcr is
extremely good because they're very
sensitive and they're extremely good
because they tell you which type of
variant of covid's got many advantages
but the lateral flows are really good at
helping to determine whether someone is
infectious at that point to other people
thank you let's go to hugh pim now from
bbc news
thank you prime minister
would you say it's now unlikely or
highly unlikely that further
restrictions will be introduced in
england
and a question for sir patrick and sir
chris
how worried are you about what might yet
happen and what do you think might be a
threshold requiring further
action well
hugh thank you very much i i
just want to go back to what i was
saying to to david earlier on we'll we
will monitor everything very closely we
clearly can't uh rule anything out but
our
what we're trying to do is take a a
balanced approach uh where we we rely on
people to to implement plan b
carefully to to think about and to to
behave carefully with other people and
the people are doing that you can tell
that people have really uh responded to
this and and and they're doing their
absolute best in spite of the extreme uh
transmissibility of omicron uh what
we're also doing is is massively
accelerating the
booster rollout and it's it's it's gone
incredibly fast
i think that
at the moment uh it it depends and uh
to be absolutely uh frank with you i
think it depends on the uh
the the whether the
virus will
behave in the way that perhaps it's
behaved in uh in south africa whether it
peaks how quickly uh it blows through
uh
but if you are if you ask me to guess
would say have a as i said earlier on i
said i would say we have a good chance
of getting through
uh the omicron wave uh without the need
for for further restrictions and without
the need certainly for a lockdown i
think that the reason we're in that
position unlike many other countries uh
in the world certainly unlike many other
countries in in europe is that we just
have such a high level now of of booster
protection but that is no reason for
everybody not to get more
so
in terms of the um
what do we think going forward well we
know two things
well and that is this is very
transmissible and we have
extraordinarily high levels of infection
at the moment as indeed to many other
countries
what do we think going forward well we
know two things
well and that is this is very
transmissible and we have
extraordinarily high levels of infection
at the moment as indeed to many other
countries
so large numbers of people have the
disease we also know that this is not as
severe there's a reduced chance of
hospitalization that's now clear
it's a mixture of the virus itself
perhaps being less severe and the
immunity that's in the population
but the chance is down by somewhere
between 50 and 70 percent in terms of
getting into hospitalization
so
those two things
together mean we've got a chance of more
people going into hospital because of
the degree of infection and some lesser
chance because of the mildness what we
don't know and these are two things that
we don't know that are key we don't know
exactly when the peaks going to occur or
how big the peak is going to be that's
one thing that will determine
how much
disease comes on in terms of
hospitalization and the second really
important thing
is that this has largely been an
infection amongst younger people up
until now and it's moving up the age
range now and as it moves up the age
range you would expect to see more
hospitalizations and we don't know for
sure how that's going to manifest and
what degree of disease so
i think with the degree of infection
we've got we're going to see more
hospitalizations for sure
15 000 per day at the moment that i
expect to increase
and that of course will be associated
with increased pressure and ultimately
uh of course with some fatalities as
well
and i think uh what we now need to look
for is when this peaks and starts to
come down
let's add to that and i think that from
a health service point of view
i kind of divided into uh some some
different sort of groups
i don't think we think that the icu
pressure is going to be what it was in
previous like it was in previous waves
but there is very substantial pressure
on the emergency service part ambulances
andes and and my colleagues in the nhs
through the emergency side are having an
extremely difficult time because they've
got a simultaneous uh wave of people
coming in with covid on top of the usual
winter pressures
and you've got a wave of people who are
off sick because they have got covered
or indeed for other reasons but kobe did
very substantially contribute to that
as patrick said we would expect the peak
in younger people to come before the
peak in older people so it may well be
that the workforce problems start to
decrease
before we start to see any decrease in
uh the number of people coming to
hospital in fact they could still work
very well still they're going up for
some time so i think i would just
associate those two and of course
workforce problems also apply to things
like people's transport uh all the
critical services and and so on so i
think they will come to they will end up
in two slightly different places because
of this age effect
in terms of thresholds uh for the nhs
it's less so there is a single threshold
and more that little by little
routine and then urgent but not
emergency and then so on things are
rolled back so it's a little by little
the nhs has to retreat to the most
urgent things over time and obviously we
hope that they don't they
that we can still keep urgent but
non-emergency services running uh
everywhere but in every winter there's
pressures in every winter there are
times when hospitals have some
difficulties what could of course will
do is make that considerably more
difficult so it'll be patchy in
different areas of the country it'll be
patchy at different points along the
epidemic uh and it won't reach a
threshold but there will certainly be
some hospitals some areas of the country
which will come under very substantial
pressure over the next couple of weeks
and again just to build on something
that we said at the outset when you
could see how transmissible omicron was
there were three things really that
caused the big worry hospitalizations as
a key thing to keep an eye on
staff absences as a second and the
things like the testing infrastructure
become incredibly stretched as you get
to these very
high numbers and therefore become
difficult to operationalise
thanks very much hugh uh erie morgan of
itv
thank you prime minister you say that we
have a chance to ride this wave out
without having extra restrictions but
isn't the cost of that patient care are
you absolutely confident that all
patients will be cared for safely in the
coming weeks
thanks emily well
of course i want to thank the the nhs
for what they're doing they're doing an
amazing job and yes and as i've said
before i know that they are now as chris
and patrick have also said that the nhs
is now under uh a lot of pressure
but i'm also confident that we can uh
get through it and what we're doing is
supporting the nhs in
any way
that we can uh and and we will continue
to do that but
what we what we need to do
is to remember a few things first of all
lockdowns further restrictions are not
cost free they're not cost free for uh
for lies for livelihoods for for life
chances uh closing schools these are
very very difficult uh things to to to
do and have and have long-term
consequences and as as everybody can see
although omicron does cause lots of
hospitalizations uh it does a result in
at the moment uh pretty clearly
resulting in fewer people in icu
and and thankfully at the moment
certainly less mortality than we've seen
from other variants so that's why
uh we think the balanced approach that
we're taking is the is the right one and
uh to keep going with plan b plus uh
this acceleration of the of the booster
campaign and and that's the the balance
that we're that we're striking
thanks uh emily ben kentish lbc
thank you promise the two questions to
you if i may firstly your winter plan
for tackling covid says the government
is committed to doing whatever it takes
to prevent the nhs from being
overwhelmed but as beds fill up and one
in ten staff are off sick operations are
cancelled and more and more trusts
declare critical incidents isn't the nhs
already overwhelmed and you're not doing
very much at all to stop it and secondly
if i could on the issue of staff
absences that you've touched on at lbc
we've been hearing about lots of nhs
workers who say that even now they
haven't been given the ffp3 grade
medical masks to protect them from covid
others say they can't access lateral
flow tests to prevent them having to
isolate what would your response to them
be and if i could just ask professor
witty uh sir chris very quickly how
frustrated are you as a medic as sir
chris about the number of beds that are
being taken up by people who have
rejected the offer of a vaccine thank
you
thanks very much ben well look uh so on
your point about uh ffp303 uh masks and
uh and and lateral flow tests i'll i
will take that up but you know we're
doing everything we can to make sure
that the the nhs is is supplied with all
the ppe uh that uh that they need and uh
generally speaking there's been a heroic
effort to uh to get people what their
what they are gonna perhaps ask uh chris
to to comment on that in a minute but on
your on your basic point uh ben about
you know is the nhs overwhelmed well
look i mean the numbers are high
the numbers of people going into
hospital right now are high that's
that's clear and uh there are there are
uh 15 000 uh currently in a covered
patients in the nhs in england those as
you'll have heard from chris and not all
of those uh are there
wholly and entirely because
of kovid some of them uh perhaps 25 30
have contracted uh nosocomial
infections you've got to think about uh
that factor you've also got to recognize
that
this is a a milder
variant in the sense that it keeps
people in hospital perhaps for a shorter
period that's not in any way to minimize
the the pressure on the nhs now uh it's
not where it was
clearly it's not where it was in the
january uh peak uh yet uh the best way
that i think we can uh
prevent that is is to continue with the
strategy that we've we've set out and
that is everybody uh being sensible
following the the guidance uh
implementing plan b
but also getting boosted into your point
then about uh people who haven't been uh
vaccinated i mean how absolutely crazy
it is
absolutely crazy that there are two
million slots this week
for people to get vaccinated and yet uh
the the the majority of people uh in icu
for covid uh are not vaccinated with 61
and the overwhelming majority of uh of
those uh in icu have not been uh boosted
i mean really uh it this is a
it's it's sad
but it's also a huge opportunity for us
uh to try to to correct it and i just
say to people you know
the boosters the vaccines really are the
way forward
uh you you the prime minister asked me
to comment quickly on ffp3 i mean i
think there are two separate questions
really there's a question about what a
technical question for which there is a
debate about what are the situations
where it's useful and which are the
situations where it isn't nobody wishes
to wear an ffp3 if they don't need it
they're not much fun to work in uh but
on the other hand they must have them
when they are in the right place and
that's a technical discussion and then
there with several different views on it
and then there's a second separate
question of if people do need it is it
available and that and in that situation
we are far better place than we were
last year but of course if anyone hears
of shortages people need to escalate
that because it is critical that people
do have the kit that's needed when uh
when they get to the point where they
need it
on the one you ask me about uh did i
would i get frustrated with the word you
think i i would say i i my experience of
having talked to people in that
situation is i'm rather saddened because
not the great majority of them they're
not anti-vaxxers in the ordinary sense
with sort of really weird ideas
but uh essentially there are three
questions people want to know and answer
to they want to know is this disease
important enough to be vaccinated
against and uh i can say very clearly
the fact that in hospital means pretty
clearly this is a serious disease this
is a serious serious disease the second
question is do the vaccines work well
we're very confident the vaccines work
as i say 88 protection is our current
estimate may change a bit in terms of
reducing the chance of you going to
hospital even more almost certainly
going into intensive care as the prime
minister said and the third thing and
this is where the misinformation there
is around on the internet uh a lot of it
deliberately placed uh is a problem
is they worry about side effects and
that's understandable and it is the job
of health professionals not to get
frustrated by that but simply to say
look let's go to all of your questions
properly and systematically and say you
know which ones are fair and which ones
and as in many cases are really
completely untrue but have been put into
the public domain often deliberately to
scare people so insofar as i i'm
frustrated it's simply people
deliberately trying to scare fellow
citizens away from getting something
which is going to be potentially
life-saving for them certainly
stop them getting a hospital admission
and protect people around them the final
thing people of course then want is
convenience and that's what the booster
program has allowed is a massive
expansion of our capacity
and if people have not yet had a vaccine
at all now is a very good time to get it
there's a lot of capacity and we really
would like to use it whether it's first
second or third third doses that people
are needing
thank you uh ben rowena mason guardian
and
to the prime minister what is your
definition of the nhs becoming
overwhelmed and is this still your
guiding principle
that you would bring in restrictions if
the nhs is at that point because a lot
of people working in the health service
feel that that's been reached already
and to uh the chief scientific officer
and chief medical officer do you agree
with andrew pollard of the jcvi that we
can't keep on um getting uh booster jabs
every six months that it's unsustainable
for that to just keep happening
forevermore
uh
thank you very much bro you know well
look i think the nhs is under huge
pressure i won't provide a definition of
what uh being overwhelmed uh would would
constitute because i think that
different trusts in different places at
different moments uh will feel at least
temporarily overwhelmed and anybody who
you know in hospitals at the moment uh
are sending out signals as you know
rowena's saying uh that they they're
feeling uh the pressure hugely and i
understand that and i and i and i thank
them for uh the work that they're
they're doing it's absolutely fantastic
um
there are not as many uh coveted
patients in uh the nhs now as there were
in the january
peak not by
a long way but uh sadly uh the numbers
are likely to grow there are the various
mitigations that i've i've already
mentioned uh
the the relative uh mildness and itself
of the shortness of stay uh and so on
the the fact that people don't go into
icu uh nearly so much
and uh and so on as as chris and patrick
have already said
but
in the end it's it's it's it's people in
the hospital uh it's the pressure on a
e's it's the ambulances arriving uh
that's that's creating the
the
that huge sense of of pressure and i
totally understand that i've just got to
say to people uh that uh and i as i said
yesterday there will be a difficult
period for our wonderful nhs for the
next few weeks because of omicron i just
think that we have to get through it as
best as we possibly can we will give the
nhs all the support uh that we can but
in the meantime the thing we've got to
do
as as responsible members of the public
is follow the uh the guidance uh try to
stop transmission as much as we can and
uh get boosted and you know
it's i can see the limit in the value of
of people like me uh you know endlessly
uh saying from uh our pulpits you know
come on and get vaccinated uh we do need
everybody uh to join this movement you
know
and uh there are many many uh
evangelists for this now and it we need
everybody to to to to build the movement
peop there is a big opportunity to turn
this around nine million people still to
get a vaccine uh now's the time
in terms of the the vaccine question
um what's the good news is that as you
get um vaccinated more the immune system
broadens its response
so that it covers more variants so the
immune system tends to get broader as
you get more exposed to infection or you
get
vaccinated
and
there are different parts of the immune
system some of which have a very long
lasting memory of what you've seen
before and therefore will provide some
durability
i think andrew pollard's right it would
be
a situation that isn't tenable to say
everyone's gonna need to be
having another vaccine every three or
six months that's not the long-term view
of where this goes to there will be some
people who may require an additional
dose
but longer term i would think that as
this becomes a disease which is endemic
in other words we have it circulating it
comes back every year
it will be something like an annual
vaccine like flu or something of that
order which is moves to exactly which
vaccine that is we don't know yet that's
going to be something that people will
work on over the next months and and in
years to come as well as we think about
long-term vaccine strategies so i don't
see this as being something that you end
up having a vaccine from as frequently
as we do now we need that because it's
the very early stages of this disease
and we needed to get boosted for this
variant at this moment so i think
there'll be a change over time and this
will settle into a much more routine
type of vaccine program as we have for
other
infectious diseases
thank you uh rowena harry cole son
the son
thank you uh prime minister you said it
will become increasingly normal for
three jabs uh to be required on vaccine
certification when are you planning on
making that the rule in in britain and
wouldn't it be totally unfair given that
millions of people who've suffered from
omicron over this christmas period have
to wait for 28 days to get their jab so
can you rule that out until february and
um prime minister if i may can i draw
your attention to an article you wrote
for the sun on the 31st of may 2016
where you said that if we leave the eu
energy bills will be lower for everyone
eu rules mean we can we cannot take that
off those bills and the least wealthy
are particularly hard you went on to
directly promise when we vote leave we
will be able to scrap this unfair and
damaging tax yet as prime minister
you're refusing calls to cut bat or
scrap v80 on energy bills what's changed
or were you misleading voters
uh not at all but uh on on the uh on
your point about uh certification and um
and the booster uh look i mean i i i
understand what you're what you're
saying harry and uh we certainly don't
want to do anything that's unfair to to
anybody but uh clearly there will be
countries that are going to start uh
saying
for travel purposes for instance uh that
uh getting a booster is their uh their
condition for allowing uh brits to to
arrive there so it will be very much to
people's advantage let me put it that
way uh it would be very much people's
advantage uh to to get uh your booster
and uh when we propose to change the
definition of uh vaccine certification
uh we'll be sure to give people plenty
of uh of time and plenty of uh of
opportunity and i take your point about
the unfairness of for people who've had
omicron over
over christmas that is a very a very
reasonable point but on your point about
um
vat on on energy bills i mean i think it
is slightly paradoxical uh that this is
now being campaigned for uh by people
who actually wanted to remain in the eu
and and still do uh when uh it would be
impossible to deliver uh within the eu
uh we will continue to listen uh to
businesses and consumers about how to
abate uh the cost of uh of energy harry
and uh in the meantime in the meantime
there is there are all sorts of things
uh that we can do to help people and and
i appreciate the the the difficulties
that people are uh are are facing
because of the uh the
the increase in gas prices uh but you
know where we're we've got the uh the
warm home discount 140 pound a rebate on
energy bills uh winter fuel payments uh
that cover 11.4 million pensioners and
uh cold weather payments and and so on
as well as a 500 million pound uh
uh
contribution through a local government
to help
those who need it most harry i'm not
ruling out uh further measures and you
are quite right to draw attention as i
did in that piece
to the potential uh that is contained in
uh the
freedom to uh to regulate our own uh our
own v.a.t whether the the argument as
you know is that uh it's a bit of a
blunt instrument and uh the difficulty
is that uh you end up uh
also cutting fuel bills for a lot of
people who
perhaps don't need the support in quite
the direct way
that we need to give it we need to help
people who are in
fuel poverty the most but as i say
we will listen to
to consumers and uh and to businesses
as as we go forward and we are certainly
very and rishi sunak is very very
mindful of the of the
increase in energy prices and the effect
of the increase in energy prices on
people up and down this country and we
are going to do what we can
to help
chris anything you want to say about
energy prices
okay
uh
good uh who is next who's we got one
more
to go it's nick cecil the standard
thank you
first to the prime minister and to sir
chris
given the clovis situation in london and
the fact that so many central london
businesses have been so hard hit by the
plan b measures and omicron concerns
what is your message for people about
returning to youth pubs restaurants and
clubs in central london
to sir patrick do you think the omicron
wave has now peaked in london
and if so given the evidence from south
africa how quickly could cases fall
and finally prime minister
as a former mayor of london will you
push for a long-term sustainable funding
deal for transport for london to help
the city to recover
um
chris uh who's but who's doing like
who's doing good in london
we both find different ways
um in terms of a message i'm gonna i'm
gonna answer that rather indirectly
uh and that is that the reason that um
so until we've actually had the peak
in the most vulnerable
that is the people who are most likely
to go to hospital
any measures that are taken that help
pull the peak down slow it down
are beneficial in terms of reducing the
height of the wave and that is having an
effect on businesses on homes and above
all on the nhs and individuals people's
health
so
people have been incredibly
uh responsive and i think we should all
be incredibly grateful for the way
people responded to the fact that there
is a need unfortunately no one would
want it but there is a need for people
to be very careful still as the prime
minister said to work from home as prime
minister said to use mass but also to uh
to prioritize as we've talked about
several times uh before
that you know the response to that is
one of the reasons why the rates have
not gone up even faster and even further
obviously hopefully there will come a
point uh in the not too distant future
when the rates are coming down and
that's the point of which i think these
kind of things are much easier to
address but while before we've reached
the peak in the most vulnerable people
uh i think we need to keep the messaging
really really steady on this
shall i build on that for the yeah in
question um
so
in terms of has it reached a peak in
london
the answer is there is no evidence it's
clearly reached a peak and whilst it may
be the case that in the younger age
groups this is flattening off or
possibly even beginning to come down
not least because they had such a big
wave of infection
that is not true in the older age groups
it's still going up in the older age
groups so i think it would be very wrong
and chris has alluded to this
to suggest that there's a peak which
means it's all over in london
it may well be flattening in some of the
younger age groups but it's in the older
age groups where we have the biggest
risk of this turning into
hospitalization and severe complications
and that is definitely not the case yet
so we need to keep watching we don't
know when the peak is going to occur or
how big it's going to be
but we need to see it happen in all the
age groups not just call it when one age
group looks as though it's turning
and then
just to build on the other point about
um plan b
it wasn't plan b alone that was
important to bring it down it was the
behavior that everyone took up really
well in the run-up to christmas and over
the holiday period to change their
behaviors to try and reduce social
contacts as initially suggested by jenny
harris and chris before christmas that's
a really important part of this and
until we've got to
the older age groups coming down it's
important that we retain that caution
yeah and nick on your on your point
about uh transport for for london uh
never forget that it was left with a
very considerable uh sum of money by the
the outgoing uh the previous uh mayor
who who you know left the coppers full
uh and uh not not least to the the cross
roll and everything else however uh we
are where we are and it is vital that
our great capital city has got to be
able to uh to move around uh of course
ridership has been down uh because of
the pandemic but i know you and i uh and
the current mayor and nick devoutly hope
that that ridership uh will come back
and uh one day it will come back without
marks on uh we hope and uh our city will
be uh our capital city will be buzzing
uh again uh and so it's vital that
london uh is properly uh provided for
but what it also requires is a mayor uh
who's going to uh institute a sensible
uh and pragmatic affairs policy uh and
not the uh the retrograde one that we
saw uh the uh uh the early stage of the
of the current mayor's uh term so that's
what we're uh that's what we're looking
to uh to achieve okay uh on on that the
unesc perspective wanna say anything
about uh affairs in uh on london
transport i think uh we will conclude it
there thank you everybody thank you
you